but speaking of fostering confusion
the very radical and extreme and
dangerous lives of tick tock account
committed harassment and terrorism once
again uh this time against a woman
yesterday by reposting a video that she
posted a tick tock
in the video this woman a mother
apparently and tragically
explains
what is in her mind a developmentally
appropriate way to talk about sex and
gender with a young child listen
here's a developmentally appropriate way
to talk to toddlers about bodies and
gender
you know the body parts that your diaper
or your panties or your underwear cover
those are called privates
everyone has privates
private means that they belong to you
and only you
in the front
everybody has genitals
but there are different kinds of
genitals
some genitals
are called a penis
some are called a vulva
others
look maybe a little bit
like each in some ways or kind of like
neither
or somewhere in between
people with those kind of genitals are
called intersex
when babies are born
parents sometimes
guess their gender
based on their genitals they tend to
guess boy for babies who have a penis
and girl for babies who have a vulva
sometimes parents guess wrong though
and that's okay everybody makes mistakes
sometimes
people whose parents guessed wrong about
their gender are called transgender
so
she says that
here's a developmentally appropriate way
to talk to toddlers about gender but she
misspoke um
what she meant to say is here's an
extremely creepy way to confuse a
helpless young child with a bunch of
insane [ __ ] invented by pedophile
sexologists in the 1960s
tomato's motto i suppose that's what she
meant to say now notice how this
pink-haired freakazoid starts off right
away by introducing intersex
to the toddler
rather than giving the basic simplest
facts to the child she spends time
talking about genetic anomalies that
affect like .05
of the population
now it's true of course technically
that a very small minority of people are
born with physically ambiguous genitalia
this doesn't mean they don't have a
biological sex but just that determining
their sex is a little more difficult in
these very very rare cases
why would you mention this to a toddler
though
it's like if you were on a plane with
your three-year-old and you leaned over
and said so johnny planes go in the sky
sometimes they fly all the way through
the sky and land safely sometimes they
crash and everybody dies sometimes they
blow up in the air sometimes they fly
into buildings
now
that would technically be true but you
wouldn't say that to a toddler unless
you your intention was to traumatize him
because a child that age doesn't
understand statistics or probabilities
or the distinction between things that
are common and things that are rare
he especially won't understand the
distinction when you phrase it in a way
that is designed to make it seem like
the rare occurrence is just as common as
the common occurrence
so you talk to your child about plane
crashes that way if you want him to
think that planes crash all the time and
you talk to your child about intersex
that way or at all if you want him to
think that intersex is just as common as
normal bodies
from here the psycho with the crazy eyes
goes from misleading her child to
straight up lying
she says that parents and doctors guess
whether a baby is a boy or a girl based
on genitalia as i told you last week
this guess thing is the new talking
point it's the new euphemism
it used to be sex assigned at birth
which was already misleading enough
now it's sex guest at birth
and they go with guess instead of a sign
because
guess sounds even more arbitrary and
baseless and yet and yet they still
admit
that most of the time
the guess is correct
well why would that be the case
why does it just so happen that parents
who guess boy based on a penis are
almost always right
of course they're not almost always
right they're always right but
i mean even based on the demented logic
we heard in that clip
according to her
the guess quote unquote is almost always
right
why is that
if it's a 50 50 guess
and there are billions of guesses being
made across the world
then shouldn't the guest be wrong about
50 of the time shouldn't 50 of the world
be trans
because trans by this way of thinking is
simply the result of a wrong guess
that's all
with so many billions of guesses
how can there be so few wrong guesses
well these are the kinds of questions
that we as critical thinking rational
adults can ask
these are the holes that we can punch in
the nonsense that people like this woman
are spewing
but even the smartest toddler in the
world
isn't going to notice these problems
he doesn't have enough information about
the world to think critically about this
he'll just accept whatever he's told
and he will become deeply profoundly
despairingly confused and lost and that
is all by design that's the plan
by these grooming predator ghouls
and that's why they are once again
canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated